the Joe Rogan experience the L AFC team
is has been constructed by some pretty
great folks in LA like like Will
Ferrell's a big impetus behind the team
and Mia Hamm and and all these great
folks that kind of tailored it to Los
Angeles and my first game was you could
I've never felt that kind of pride in
Los Angeles like I've always sort of
felt like a transplant here and I've
been here for almost 20 years and it was
incredible
well the the game itself is is
mind-blowing like it's non-stop and that
like the physical feat of and I grew up
playing soccer so I love to watch it I
love to play like it's great but the
sense of community here and the
enthusiasm and just the the way that
they have built the stadium in downtown
Los Angeles it was it was heavy did you
you want a hand of heart I did I felt it
I felt it so deeply you can make fun of
me all you want look at that gorgeous
Stadium will you a soccer fan excuse me
football fan can we just come up with
one [ __ ] name we can't call it
football okay why because we have
American football we are listen we're
all in this together
I'm just talking about names I look I
don't even like football I think of
they're real and they take those [ __ ]
helmets off savages I'm joking these are
just jokes [ __ ] corn pads I think you
should play football from [ __ ]
hamster wheels just giant hamster wheels
slamming each other
if we're gonna have shoulder passes to
pad up the [ __ ] entire area around
you while we playing games hundreds of
yards you're in the center power in it
slamming each other what's eliminate CTE
we just need bigger we needed golf
courts eyes areas to play on that's
actually not even men that was the guys
in the transitionary period they were
transitioning that was right when in
yeah see the original men were leather
helmets yeah well here's the thing
here's a little shout-out to our Native
American friends one of the problems
when they first started inventing
football is the Native American teams
would [ __ ] the white teams sure they had
these dudes were like you know college
educated you know trying to learn how to
play this new game and these Native
American dudes would put the smash down
on the [ __ ] old school angry that the
grandpa got scalped yeah they've been
bison for a thousand generation put that
real smart it wasn't like they were
making millions of dollars which player
you know they would this is a new thing
though they had real jobs and then
football yeah so this is the story it's
like if you google how I'm sorry how
American Indians saved the sport of
football it's an amazing story and it's
the the really the origins of the
beginning of football they barely had
pads dead like these little shoulder
[ __ ] things that like dudes have now
in sport coats to make themselves look
like they you know look more boxy crazy
like it's the male equivalent of a
push-up bra there's a dude with like
padded shoulders and support code yeah
whenever I buy like a vintage jacket I
take the shoulder pads out because I
feel like a douche bag
[Music]
I think there was an NPR like a radio
lab podcast on [ __ ] yeah people died
playing football row people playing even
I was that in a year yeah 19 people died
playing it in a timeline one year oh my
god those people are different
[Applause]